of the many people who suffer from long
cove it is the author michael rosen who
has written books like
going on a bear hunt of course more
recently many different kinds of love
which is about
his experience of being very ill
with covert its cell phone now with long
curve and we can talk
to michael now very good evening to you
michael and you know our sympathies to
you may this has been going on now for
you
for more than a year isn't it just take
us back to that experience you were very
very
poorly indeed originally with kovid in
intensive care
yes i was in intensive care for 48 days
in all i was in a
an induced coma for 40 of those 48 days
and when you're in intensive care for
that long then you have to rehabilitate
because your body's been deconditioned
so i had to learn how to
stand up and how to walk and um and here
i am now i'm sitting down at the moment
i'm not actually walking as you can see
um but i've lost the sight most of the
sight in my left eye
most of the hearing in my left ear also
have to put that the right way around
i get muddled sometimes don't lose your
sight from your ear
and um i've lost the um the scents in my
toes i've got numb toes i did have blood
clots
you just heard about the blood thinning
well i was on those for a while
and i probably lost these faculties here
because i had
um well it's called micro bleeds in my
brain which which knocked out the nerves
so that's that's a sort of brief summary
for you that's my bulletin
yeah as i say my goodness me poor you
and do you
still feel just tired and lousy
uh i broke my record today i did three
laps around my neighborhood which is
mazwell hill instead of the usual two
so i broke my record on there i did used
to get what i called alternate day
syndrome where i'd do something quite
active one day and then
be completely sort of flattened out the
next um
and i seem to be getting better that
doesn't seem to happen quite so much so
i'm getting over that fatigue element
i think i'm probably a bit breathless
but as i mostly wear a mask it's a bit
hard to tell but i think i'm a bit more
breathless than i used to be i mean i am
nearly 75 so um but even so i think
i think i'm getting better so i'm pretty
nearly a year since
um yeah i was a i'm a year since i was
admitted
that's right exactly a year so um
that gives you a sort of sense of how
long it's been going on i did also lose
my
big toenails rather mysteriously there
was just sort of blood there instead of
toenails
sorry this is probably fine what is
eating now sorry about that
um so some people very sadly have had
what's the equivalent of frostbite
they've actually
lost their toes um so you know there's a
it's quite a wide range it's quite a big
array of
symptoms and syndromes that people are
getting yeah and you
i mean you mentioned me talking there to
one of the medical experts dr banerjee
there but um
have you got together and there are
communities i know
of people suffering these these symptoms
and as you described there just
so many different ones is that a help as
well just sharing those experiences
and then discussing perhaps you know
what works for you
might work for somebody else who you're
in contact with
yes indeed there's a facebook page that
i belong to and um
we sometimes get on there and and
obviously it's quite it's
it's nice to be able to complain or
fetch as you might say in yiddish
so we get to kind of fetch a facebook
group
um where people moan and say say what's
wrong with them and it does help
it does help a lot i mean particularly
if um
i mean they're very strange not so
serious symptoms so for example
um i grow a kind of sand on my skin
and then i if i get it wounded of any
sort
um the skin granulates that means you
sort of produce extra skin and so the
the wound doesn't heal up and so people
say are you getting that or if
particularly the sight and the hearing
people are
talking about that i was just walking up
my street
and a neighbor of mine stopped and said
that her mum had got covered and
one of her eyes had got fogged just as
mine is so you suddenly think
you're not alone and the moment you feel
not alone
my own feeling always is is that you
rejoin the human
race because there's a time when you're
sitting there and feeling
miserable you you somehow feel as if
it's um it's just picked you off
and it's quite nice to rejoin the human
race occasionally
and michael you and i have something in
common uh we're both arsenal fans
viewers please don't judge us some
hopefully um yeah there you go hopefully
uh tomorrow night's game against
liverpool will give you a bit of a list
yeah i think it's saturday actually
dermot but anyway so i'm swatching no i
thought it was a weekend you're right
yes that's right hang on there um yeah
so uh
yes well i'm i'm holding out for that i
must say
it was one of the things cheering me up
quite a lot when i came home and
occasional times that arsenal one
and i'd sit on the sofa with my youngest
and um and i could tell him not to punch
me as well because of the blood thinning
i said i might bleed to death so don't
punch me if we score you know
[Laughter]
might not be a problem against him okay
michael really good talking
joan please please get well soon glad to
glad to know your writing again as well
michael rosen there
thank you